this theorem actually has a name it was
called the happy ending theorem
and what happened was that a woman
mathematician esther klein
picked up the problem when she was
abroad and brought it back and eredish
and secondaries thought about it
and
it turns out that shortly thereafter
securish and esther clan got married and
they were married until the in their
90s
so
if i put five points
on the table here and the plane so that
no three are in a straight line so
that's one way to do it or i could do it
like this or i could
do it a different way
what you're looking for if you're
looking for
a convex set of four points and what
does convex mean convex means as you're
moving around the polygon say you're
going from here to here to here so i
went all the way around the edges you're
always turning left you never turn right
this is the idea of a convex polygon and
a polygon that's not convex is something
like this so if i were to go around the
outside of this polygon i hear i turn
right then i turn left then i turn left
then i turn left so it kind of dented in
so you're looking for a convex polygon
now here's a set of five points can i
have a convex yes here's a convex one
right here how about this one well
that's a little harder but here's one
you don't have to use all five no no you
only get four points so the question is
now if i just gave you four points like
this then there is no convex foregone
here because you got to use all four
points and so it'd be stuck with five
points you have to get a convex foregone
and there's very beautiful nice proof of
that if the outside only had four or
five points then you could use those
points and get your convex four-sided
figure
but if it didn't so if you had a
triangle and two points on the inside
okay so look at these
five points
then if you just take this line
and extend it through then it will hit a
side over here and then these
four points for my convex and gun so the
question is suppose you wanted not a
convex foregone you wanted a convex
five-sided figure if you put enough
points down unless you get a five
yes and the answer is yes if you put
nine points down no three in a straight
line
you must form a convex five-sided figure
someplace and nine's the best possible
with eight you can prevent it with eight
you can prevent it and just very
recently
people showed that if you put 17 points
down
you must get a convex six-sided figure
and 16 is not enough so it's a beautiful
conjecture of erdish and george securish
who is his long-time collaborator that
if you want a convex n-sided figure and
n-gone
then it's enough to put two to the n
minus two plus one points that should
imply that you would get a convex end
gone and that would be best possible
there is a way to put only 2 to the n
minus 2
and not get 1. so if n is equal to say 6
you want a convex six gone then 2 to the
6 minus 2 plus 1 which is 17. and that
was that recent result 17 is enough and
if you put n is equal to
4 then you want the convex 4 gone 2 to
the 2 plus 1 is 5. that's our 5. okay so
it's the guess is that that's exactly
the right answer and i offer a thousand
dollars kind of in their decision to
prove that that's the right answer or
proof it's not the right answer a
thousand bucks of your money proved or
disproved well i have some yes i have
some heritage money left for this
emergency in case people solve these
problems right so that's not that's not
that's not a fact yet that's just no
this is a conjecture there are many
papers and surveys and
and it's just one of these kind of
innocent
geometrical problems again in the spirit
of ramsey theory which shows that in a
complex situation there's a certain
order within it in the complex situation
there's a bunch of endpoints in the
plane and the order
is
a
ngon that's convex it was known to n
equals four
it was right away right away and five
was done of 30 40 years ago
and six was just done and they used a
fair amount of computer calculation
because you have to look at all the
different configurations
of putting 17 points down in the plane
and there are a lot of different
possibilities and you want to check that
each one of them must have a convex six
gone and they did and that's done but
now the next case is kind of beyond
computation so you need
your brain once again
right now computers aren't as
aren't up to it for replacing our brains
at least not up to it yet
zach
that stack is 7.6
trillion threes high and you start from
the top and work your way down and you
get an almighty number you get a number
that is absolutely
off the chart